okay so I'll try and give an overview of
Julia itself as a language and then a
bit about the data science aspect of it
what we've got and where we're headed
and then sort of how it can interact
with other software in particular Python
and our I guess we're the two main ones
people are interested in for data
science work so what is Julia know so I
should start firstly I I work for Julia
nice to be at UCL until six months ago
you know a statistician but now I work I
work for Julia computing full-time which
is sort of like consulting so the
company started by the founders of
language to provide consulting support
got some products coming out as well but
that sort of our main income stream is
funding the development of language as
well so Julia sort of the four words we
like to throw about so it's a modern
high-performance language for technical
computer dynamic language for technical
computing so modern
basically we're tried to learn the
lessons of the last sixty years
high performance so we want to say our
aim is to be as fast as any other fast
language as fast as you for trans your
C++ is etc so anything what people
typically view as fast thing we just by
dynamic we want I mean definition of
dynamic language is a bit vague but
we're basically in as easy to use a
straightforward python as your pythons
your R's etc and then finally techno
computing so our core target is
technically you can use for other things
but basically anything involving numbers
or arrays of that sort of thing is
basically that's what we're really
focusing on through so why Julia
fundamentally if you want to write fast
efficient code in a very easy to use
elegant dynamic language and so our
original search sales pitch is that you
avoid this two thing which problem when
you have to have you or your high-level
code and then you sort of your nice bit
of code and you have to chuck it convert
all the inner loops into C to make it
fast
so we're trying to say you can just use
the one link for everything you don't
have to do this
you know rewrite bits and I don't think
I come from using our before a long time
ago so you know if you ever dug in it
our functions if you type the function
into the commit into the repple that
gives you the function but then if you
dig down far enough eventually just
gives you some calling some seed library
underneath and so yeah you know
basically the idea is you can all do
this and because of that it's very easy
to peek under the hood so you can most
of Julia itself is written in Julia
there's remarkably little of it is
actually written basically the only bits
that are the bits that tie into the LVN
backend which is the compiler that we
exploit and so you can actually view
actually dig all the way down to see
where how your code goes but not only
that you can also view the stage as it
goes from the code you type the code
you're using down to what it actually
goes all the way down to the Machine
level code that's being executed on your
machine and so this is great for someone
tinker like me or someone who like those
people who like really likes to
understand what's going on it's great
especially when you're trying to make a
code faster because you can see exactly
where the bottlenecks are and you know
how you can't make it first though it's
free basically I don't think you could
realistically come out with a
programming language these days that
isn't free and open source like no one
who's gonna take you up on that it's fun
I said it's I don't know I mean most
people who found Python it I become
Python no you like you know I think this
sort of elegance of it's quite neat you
know it's kind of fun using it and I
think julia has that as well and that
sort of you know you'll burn as you dig
into it you realize how neat it is and
all these nice constructions and it's a
lot of fun and finally it plays nicely
with everything else so I they'll give
us over demo later on if the how it
interacts with our and it's very easy to
call see and then also very easy to call
our and Python and plays nicely with all
existing tool chains and so you can and
vice versa so what does it look like
so here's the sort of a nice simple
function blog some X so as you can see I
hopefully that's fairly obvious what
it's doing basically this is the you
know it's the end if you ever done have
to take the sum the log of a sum of
Exponential's this is what the code you
would end up writing a little look like
so there's a couple things going on
you notice we unlike Python use end to
end blocks so we stole that from MATLAB
so so there's no significant whitespace
so it means you can copy paste code
without me knowing about you dictation
but you know any editor will endeavor
for you what else for I equals one to
length so we're one based indexing so if
you can live with that some reason a lot
of people most data people don't care
but you know for some reason you know
hardcore CS people really have this
importance of one based indexing but you
know I don't care to be honest a bit
yeah if you can live with that it's fine
instead of having your range objects you
have this like Python whatever
but why cores brains you have one-to-one
colon link so again we've stolen that
MATLAB our notation but unlike those we
don't act that doesn't allocate a vector
that creates an object which is just
like an iterator similar to X range and
by 2 or ranging by 3 yeah so that's the
sort of thing you but I mean it looks
fairly obvious and there's an implicit
return at the end so it's fairly
hopefully that looks fairly
straightforward if you're a Python code
you'd see how you get that so as I said
very probably more heavily in sum from
MATLAB but we've got rid of all the
stupid MATLAB quirks like ran 10 doesn't
give you a matrix a 10 by 10 matrix it
just gives you a vector which so we try
to fix all those stupid things but then
we also install some good ideas for
Python on the way so basically if you're
a MATLAB or a python usually you should
pick it up within a day or so playing
around with it so that's what the limit
looks like so what how does it work
underneath so the fundamental idea and I
think it's probably more important so
Python classes and sort of you get to
them after a while learning Python types
are probably more important to Juliet in
class no Python are more fundamental so
again like a classify that every object
has a type so the type of a 1.0 is a
float 64 functions have types so type of
a function function and a type and then
types themselves are all subtypes of
datatype a roll of duck type data type
and so you declare new type through the
type keyword so type just okay so type
with two float64 arguments and then you
can construct
by just passing those two arguments in
and so something that's fairly unique
about Julia is that user declared types
as efficient as the built-in types so if
you basically it would be our complex
type for example is defined in Julia
itself and is as fast as you would you
know if you call Fortran complex code
like it's basically everything you can
do is you can anything you can make fast
you can make fast just using Julia and
so built-in types are like beta and then
R is fast you don't have to worry about
them being sort of second-class citizens
and so and they also then mirror see
struck so it's nice you know it's nicely
to play if you have to call see objects
so that makes it very easy to use the
other core idea so this is a bit of a
leap and so you think follow this along
nope I apologize but I'll try and give a
flavor of what makes Julia special is
multiple dispatch generative generic
functions of multiple dispatch so Julia
functions generic and so basically
different code paths will get called
depending on which what the are what the
types of the arguments are and so
firstly we don't have the distinction
from say Python is that the functions
don't belong to a class so methods don't
belong to a class they're separate
they're sort of a focal objects and they
don't there's notice of we separate them
out a bit and so you always call a
function by F so the function of the
front and then parentheses to call the
function B and so here I've defined a
function f with two methods first one is
a fluid has a float 64 argument that
prints it returns a string and so dollar
does string substitution as in Python
and if it's an inter it says it's an
integer so fairly straightforward
basically this is i before i when i
wrote a function i used functions base
so basically this F equals is like a
shorthand version of that function
declaration so it's great when you have
to write what one-liners which when you
start playing at multiple aspects you
find yourself writing a few more method
a few methods and this double colon is a
subtype specification and this is
entirely optional this is only used to
determine this doesn't affect
performance only determines what we call
dispatch so which which method will get
called from a particular function so if
we so if we hadn't left that if we'd
left the X off all together we could
have just written the first one without
you know without the double colon there
would be just the same function so when
you call it with a float or a knee-jerk
does it calls the correct method
basically so as I said before unlike
standard object-oriented languages we
don't take functions don't belong to a
type so basically why we do this is
because we can then take this the next
level and say why dispatch on the first
argument we can dispatch on any
combination of arguments and so here
we've now take two arguments and so FX
so if the first arguments are float64
and second arguments int we can print
this and now if it's we have sort of
four backs so for any real types so it
floats 64's and into subtypes of reals
and so we just say it's some sort of
real and then for any other object we
just say I don't know what the hell they
would print something else and so then
as we go through these you can see
exactly what gets printed for each
combination so so for any if for any two
functions that will there'll be a some
method will get called and that's what
and so you can see that's how it just
it's very simplest batch and so you have
to think a little bit clearer it takes a
little bit of time to get head around
this especially with such more
complicated things but this becomes
really powerful for things like matrix
multiplication because then you can
dispatch on what the to type you know if
you have different types of matrices
like symmetry symmetric tri-diagonal
diagonal etc you can dispatch on the
ones that best matches the the method
that best matches the two arguments you
have and so for example say we want to
show how our badge type is printed so
this is handled by the show function so
if your type show B that B but was the
object I defined earlier it just prints
the output
so as I said show is that itself is a
generic function and it has something
like 105 different methods and so you
see the first object is the first art
and all these things it takes two
arguments the first one is an i/o type
which basically says where am I going to
send it and the second one is a is the
type of the thing we want to print
so most show mitso aseye said that
there's also a generic single mat
argument method which then just prints
it to standard out so which is what so
by default if we just pass a single
object it'll just printed out of it we'd
hope so to extend it we basically say we
firstly have to import the method it
doesn't like your override in built-in
functions import the function C doesn't
Leo override built-in functions without
explicit importing and then we then just
define new method and say so you do
something like that and then now when we
just enter the object to return the
object it'll print out a nice
description long description and as I
said yeah this this sort of generic idea
becomes very very powerful and it's
quite useful unless you do a lot of
things that you can't do in sort of a
standard class method belonging to a
class type infrastructure so that's sort
of been a bit how julia works the
high-level arm so how does it work
underneath and what makes it tick and
fundamentally one of these things
there's sort of two things going on
first one is just-in-time compilation
and so basically whenever you call a
function the first time with a specific
set of types as arguments it will just
in time it will just in time compiler so
generate all the necessary machine code
then to actually call the function and
the way it does this is use this what's
known as lbm which is a basically a back
end compiler infrastructure so it's used
by clang famous leaders at most so if
you use compiling C programs on a Mac
that's what using now rust and Swift are
also adopted it and its basic it's great
basically we can take it leverage all
this work done by a fantastic compiler
engineers and implement it selves I
think whether you have one of the few
ones using the JIT stuff so we had to
sometimes push quite a few patches up to
your that working
but you know and also then lets us use
it makes incredibly easy to operate
across platforms and also a new machine
so to get the arm build working was
probably a couple days work by one
person just so entirely new architecture
basically just it was pretty
straightforward because I had a list of
machinery in place so as I said so
functions are just in compiled so that
means that they're the unit or which you
want to build things so the first time
people write a julia code they'll just
write a script and then click run and it
runs terribly slowly and that's because
it's not being JIT compiled so the first
thing you don't tell someone is just to
get me the inside a function type
function at the start and return the
value one at the end and then suddenly
it all magically becomes faster and it
works quite well that remarkably works
fairly straightforward and then why does
that work is that internally one of the
main tricks that we use is called type
inference so basically that means when
it sees the function your function it
goes through and tries to tag what type
of each the what the type of each
variable and which expression is so it
can then figure out what the result is
and so this means that there is a slight
trick to writing performant functions
which basically means you have to write
them such that they're what we call
types table and essentially that means
is that you don't want the variables to
change types as you function so if
you've got a for loop for example you
don't want to start as an integer and
then convert it to a float during the
loop because then it's changing type so
that the type inference stage can't
figure out what the variable is so for
example this is why for example you take
the square root of negative 1 it spits
out an error rather than giving you a
complex value back because if it gave
returned a complex value that means that
the digits they'd wouldn't know whether
a square root gives you a float float or
a complex number and so by insisting on
a few of these sort of things then we we
can save space another example that is
we don't have beat so integers unlike
Python we don't do if you overflow
integers you don't we don't go into
begins we just well you can either
depending if you have checking you on or
off it'll either throw an error or will
wrap around purely for speed because it
lets us do things that just pipe it that
you simply just couldn't do by
being overflowing to begins because you
know that if you sum two integers you're
getting an integer back which is one
machine instruction it's not a machine
instruction plus a branch plus an extra
chunk of memory you have to allocate for
your branch which basically so there's a
few sorts a few little things like that
we've had to make trade-offs for
performance but I think by and large
those things are certainly worth it and
the finally the other trick that becomes
really powerful and very addictive when
she started doing it is meta programming
and so if anyone's so julia has a bit of
a lot doesn't look like it has a strong
disparities as well so if anyone's
familiar with that basically idea is
that we can show expressions themselves
drill your objects so if I just think a
colon at the front of an expression at
the front of a syntax you get an
expression object and what this means is
that now I can just is that you're lets
you manipulate expressions using julia
itself so macro is a essentially
functions which operate on expressions
and transform them and they're prefixed
with this app symbol and the simplest
one is this at time so that time
basically takes a timestamp at the start
evaluates the function takes timestamp
at the end prints the result and then
returns you the actual answer and so
that's what it's done here so it's time
it's done that and then it's printed the
result and then returned the actual
answers of that expression and here you
can see what's happen with the JIT so
I've run this the firt I've run this
function just long so next I defined
earlier twice so the first time it takes
point zero five seconds on a hundred
points and allocates about two megabytes
of memory because what it's doing is
calling the just-in-time compiler doing
all the fun - fun tricks at the back
type inference JIT compiling etc and
then returns the answer second time
we're down to like fractions you know
several orders of magnitude lots faster
simply because now it's just calling it
every when it calls it it's just calling
the native compiled machine code so
straight done
and so we can see what macros do so for
example this is macro expand function so
first we have to quote it so doesn't get
expanded then we call macro expand and
this is what it looks like so it does a
few things takes a time stamp also takes
a GC expression figure out what the GC
is allocating and then prints the time
there returns the value at the end so
that's what sort of a simple example of
a macro and it generates the reason it
has all these things that six hashes in
there so it doesn't get confused about
scoping you know so you don't have
variables that overlap type things so
there's a few things it does there to be
careful so you can't sort of
accidentally call it variable same thing
as the macro does so I talked about sort
of digging down to Julia before and this
is sort of what you do so the first
stage when you run this type inference
this is what it looks like so what you
get back is this so this is the code
typed macro and so this gives you an
overview of what's actually happening
inside Julia when we cease this function
and so it looks a bit looks a bit crazy
and so it doesn't really display nicely
here but basically what you're nervous
is Julia syntax sort of Julia ruch
syntax so it's a lower level Juliet so
it gets rid of all your for loops or in
places and we go to is that sort of
thing and then it's tags each expression
with a type so you can see there's like
things so it knows an array of flu it
knows that if you pull a element out of
a array of float 64's it's a float 64
who knows sort of which symbols are in
set cetera it knows if you call log
float64 gives you a 64 back etc so it
does it does all those sort of things to
figure out the types and the next stage
is what we call is the LVM intermediate
representation so once it's on that we
then generate a bunch of code in LVM
until it to go nuts and so that's when
it starts running this optimization
passes so if anyone's ever looked at LVM
basically you think was sort of like is
a cross language assembly type language
so basically it's a very simple alik you
know each one of the very simple very
very simple language with integer
comparisons bit casts that sort of thing
loading memory allocating memory etc
doesn't it terribly exciting and then we
can keep on going all the way down to
code native so you can actually see this
is the machine code that was generated
from this function the pure assembly
you know what's being actually executed
on my machine okay again not terribly
exciting unless you read assembly
anything then it's not that exciting
assembly but when you sort of really do
it right trying to write tight loops
this sort of can be quite useful so if
you can exploit sort of assembly
operations and things like that so
macros are quite powerful so one really
neat use of essentially allows you to
embed sort of domain-specific languages
inside jeweller itself so a really good
example is this jump package so
basically lets you specify
it's an optimisation sort of
optimization language and sense yeah
let's say specifying a convex
optimization problem sort of as a
declarative language and then has sort
of a back end unless you farm it out to
various solvers like row being suplex
etcetera even it's okay in built ones as
well and it also lets you sort of like
tag various expressions that you know it
can be optimized sort of two ones like
in bounds which just disables array
checking array bounds checking so you
can which release so you can get sort of
a standard unsafe C behavior where if
you index out of an array you just get
like random memory vac so I would
encourage it but it lets you know when
you're really trying to fight for those
last few flop last few operations you
can get you there and the other one is
Cindy which since so even if anyone from
the assembly operations in a processor
ok so basically how it works
modern processors for basically we
couldn't make floating point operations
any faster so what they've done is
started chunking letting you do four
things at a time so if you're summing up
an array you don't start you don't you
know just keep adding floating point
numbers together what you're doing is it
the fastest way to do it is to add them
keep it keep for you register and then
add another four to that not other sort
of that none of the four to that
unfortunate if you write a for loop that
sums them up that's it can't do that
because that's not a valid
transformation because floating-point
operations aren't associative so what
assumed a says is rather than doing a
plus B plus a plus B then plus C then
plus D it says okay I'll let you
rearrange those pas statements such that
you can do those four at a time
and so I've just sort of I'll let you be
a do so a few things you you know if be
a little bit more generous of what you
can do and then you can get these need
for quite fast optimizations and just
like sticking these various things in
there is you know you can suddenly get
quite
quite powerful performance improvements
and so packages basically so julie has a
quite extensive and growing collection
of third-party packages 900 900 900 odd
so you can't quite compete with the sort
of Python ecosystem obviously but simply
being your new language but they're you
know huge range of various things and so
to install a package you literally just
go a package dot add within the language
itself and then it'll install it even
download binary dependencies all that
sort of stuff you know all the stuff
that Condor has recently got on the
bandwagon with we we can do as well so
it's quite useful look what just
happened there yeah
sorry that was my fault okay so a bit
about Julia and dollar signs I'm a bit
left
oh okay so as a name would suggest
distributions is basically found a
library of probability distributions and
so to load a package you just type using
and then the name of the package so each
class of distributions is essentially
its own type so to find a gap we can
define a gamut object which is a gamma
distribution just by a feeding in the
you know D equals gamma 3 to gives you a
gamete object back and so from that we
can construct various thing you know
compute means and variances of the
distribution the CDF of the distribution
so similar the SyFy type things that's
package if you use that but similar in a
vein and then random you know Brandt
calling Rand where the distribution
gives you rather than getting 0 1
variables gives you variables or in the
distribution variables that distribution
and there's a basic estimation
functionality as well if we you know fit
the MLE the normal to that random matrix
we just allocated tries to get Burton
you know chemi computes their maximum
likelihood estimator over the normal
distribution but under the hood it's
slightly more powerful in the sense of
because we how those distributions are
defined or what we call an immutable
type which miss entually means when the
computer just sees it as a is a pair of
two floating point numbers
and so what essentially this means we
can do so it's all really nice
optimizations under the sit under the
hood it can sort of stack allocate these
variables it's not impressive but it
means you can create you don't have this
overhead because of how the just-in-time
compiler works you don't have this
overhead of allocating and destroying
objects which would make this sort of
prohibitive so if you want to create new
distributions in a loop you know for
example if you doing MCMC anyone
familiar with that you have to you know
keep can you know Gibbs sampling have to
construct new distributions and then
sample from it there's no overhead to
creating and destroying those
distributions cuz they're yeah they're
not sort of objects that need to create
on the heap they're just you know
literally just some bits bits in a
register somewhere and then get thrown
away when we don't need them anymore so
just the fundamental design of it makes
it very powerful it's the same as having
just a function that was you know
calling a gamma factor calling me
incomplete gamma function we can call
CDF of the gamma as much faster in the
similar thing for multivariate
distributions as well so for example we
do a few tricks in here so like you know
I mean a sampling for distribution we
can sort of do the most efficient thing
depending on the matrix pre-computed
cholesky factors or exploit an
instruction like diagonal structures so
he's able to agonal matrix you can see
soviets and Fiat knows it's a pasture
just a single vector in it knows it's a
zero mean with diagonal normal yeah so I
can exploit they can do this of the fast
things there and then obviously called
random of a multivariate attribution
gives you re happening here sorry
I must keep pumping cut me sorry okay so
data frames basically similar to sort of
data frame in our or pandas in Python
basically columns of possibly Nile
heterogeneous so in heterogeneous
columns data structure type thing with
possible null nulls so you can construct
it just by passing vectors into a
constructor name vectors into instructor
o similarly this is at data macro which
lets you stick n A's in the vector and
makes them behave nicely you can also
pass doesn't have to be you know strings
or integers or floating-point numbers
you can pass in arbitrary julia objects
so here just part created a column of
normal distributions so we can you know
import our datasets package which is
basically all the datasets that come
with our paris our packages so we can
load the standard IRS data set and then
you can do sort of various operations on
there so indexing by a symbol gives you
a the vector gives you your column
indexing usual standard row column
indexing so one colon gives you a row of
there at the data frame and you can
subset by indexing as well and it
supports this sort of split apply
combined thing you know create by deep
layer and pen has pandas as well so
where you sort of just so by so we feed
the data set so by a variable species we
apply some function and then compute the
result so in this case we're computing
the mean of a of another things of
another variable and gadfly is a sort of
a plotting library so it's very elegant
so using get play so plot x you feed the
coordinates x or y x and y is vectors
and you get a graphic out was
particularly nice it's a graphic it
returns is an SVG with you bill
javascript so you can do like zooming
plotting zooming and panning or all
inbuilt it's also static so this isn't
doing anything fancy like calling
through to the julia back-end you can
just save this as an image and
just to get somewhere and all this stuff
will still work and it sort of inspired
by this grammar of graphics idea we've
heard about yesterday I mean the talks
and their and that but also and used by
sort of ggplot2 in our where and so you
can feed in and a place nice and data
frames so we can feed in data frame add
up this iris data frame and then so x
and y are the columns and then cola is a
columns per species column and then you
can again we get this nice graphic back
out which again for the interactive and
you specify geometries like lines or
histograms or so density plots there and
that sort of thing it's got all sorts of
other things you can set scales and you
know log scales and value that sort of
thing
GLM's journals any models we're short on
time so i want to skip this bit but yeah
generalize any models as you'd expect
yeah I'll do a little wanted to look at
the end and finally other thing I want
talk about is so that's sort of yeah
various other things for you know few
other sort of interesting things so you
know very speckies hypothesis tests and
density estimation penalize regression
wrap we don't really have a there's no
julia based deep learning library the
moment at this m8 we have like various
wrappers for things such as MX net i
think is sort of the current recommended
one and there's this sort of compute
framework which is sort of
work-in-progress the moment is to sort
of is like a dag base scheduler
distributing computing similar tasks
basically very similar tasks in python
which we heard the keynote this morning
basically finally calling other
languages and julie is very easy so see
is that inbuilt is obviously very easy
call from inbuilt so it's simply just
the c core function and then you pass
the function in the library and then
various argument types and then the
arguments so here i'm calling the power
function in the standard c math library
soul mmm that's why the limbs there i
give the return value return type and
then the input types and then pass the
two arguments and it just and it calls
the function underneath and there's
similarly other level functions there's
c function for creating c compatible
function pointers if you need to do
callbacks and things and
unsafe store on take load for literally
just pulling bits out of memory
and so that makes it and then once he
combines with metaprogramming it makes
it very very easy to wrap existing
libraries I think I was like one of the
first things that in julia was like with
rapper c librarian you know literally
took about a day or so don't get going
and then so based on this we can then
interface with the c functions of other
other languages so pike or for example
wraps python is based basically just
calling the c python api and by that
sequel so michael using Pikul will
basically start a background python
session which we can then call so pi
eval then just evaluates a string as a
Python in Python and then converts a
result back into julia object so pi eval
we call any for a pipe inner evaluated
python range and python expect the
symbolic Python list and we get back a
julia array which is sort of the
corresponding object there's this nice
PI import macro which basically creates
loads a Python module into a basic
crates of corresponding Julia module and
wraps all the functions nicely so at PI
import math loads the Python math
library and then we can call math sign
it's actually a PI object so it's just a
wrapper around the Python sine function
and then which you can just call
straight away math dot sine of zero
point two he gives a so it's calling a
Python sine function and then return the
result back obviously we haven't built
sine function but that was a everything
what to do that before other lab it's
useful if there's not a matching julier
object it just returns a PI object
containing the type which you can just
play around with and then pass back to
other things so for example if I create
PI import the decimal module and
constructor Python decimal I get this pi
object decimal back which but I can
still use that back through Pikul so
Julie doesn't support overloading opera
yet and so to call you know what were
they call d dot to integral you have to
call use the somewhat clumsy thing of
using the square brackets to integral
and then evaluating that
so and that computes the yeah
essentially is computing this Python
expression numpy arrays so numpy and
julia use exactly the same memory layout
so you can actually convert directly
between them I think one of the ways it
actually doesn't even bother allocating
memory I think it's the Python if you've
got Julia Rea past the Python I don't
think it even I think it just keeps the
just calls the Julia memory so doesn't
have to copy it which is quite nice so I
input memory you can also pass julia
functions back into Python and then
python can then call those so for
example here we call supplied optimized
via Newton iterations here we're passing
in as julia function back into the SyFy
newton method which then then about
optimizes that and gives you the i guess
that must be the maximum maximum
minimize so far I don't anyway that's
the so yeah very straightforward to use
and then there's a separate package
called pipe lot which is essentially PI
call on map pop live with a few nights
of wrapped functions so using pipe lot
and then we can just call basically the
same matplotlib syntax you would use I
have to seek pipe lot out here because
I've already defined a plot function
when I loaded a gadfly so if you're not
using both library at the same time this
would just be plot so it's just you know
simple name spacing and then yeah I get
my matplotlib graph out so our call is
the other one was to be quick overviews
this is when I've had more result for
more input on so our import is basically
as an our import function which is so it
does the same thing it starts of a
background our session there isn't our
import function which is similar to
apply import but it's not as easy to use
basically kazar has completely bonkers
syntax firstly it has multiple indexing
double single bracket more buckets but
then it also has non-standard evaluation
which lets it do all sorts of cool
things like it lets you the formula
syntax and makes ggplot2 all do do you
know do i do all these really cool
things but it's completely you know you
know because it lets you evaluate
variables in different scopes than the
one they call them and so base it
basically lets you do very cool things
what makes it really pain to call from a
sort of a state very standard language
so what we offer instead is so you can
use though or you can use what this is
called a macro string literal so
basically if you stick a letter at the
front of a stranger there that calls a
macro which kid so it is evaluated at
compile time and expands out into an
expression and so this what this does is
essentially call past this as an hour
expression and then call it so if you
kept a lot less during the trouble
passes is an hour expression and then
when it gets to a value it'll evaluate
the expression but we also do a little
bit extra and lets you substitute julier
expressions in via this dollar syntax
basically the old syntax whenever is not
valid our syntax so for example if I
define a julia vector here x equals r
and then and then call our plot with
dollar x that's not valid our syntax so
it substitutes that dollar x into passes
that into r and then gives me the our
plug back out so there I've just plotted
julia variable again we can do the same
thing with functions so i can pass in
julia functions into r and call them
from unfortunately variable doesn't work
the printing and printing doesn't work
quite as nicely but i'm trying to figure
that fix that up but still we can plant
we can plot this julia function you know
and you can do the same things lets you
call all sorts of standard so this is
the st. our libraries so here it's
called load the our library ggplot2 and
then I pass a julia data frame into
ggplot2 then create basically the same
graph I created earlier and gadfly put
in using GG put again very simple to use
just using this using this simple ass
things insects of course you sometimes
one of your results back oh we can do
mini models as well but then so in each
case little any model what I get this is
our objective expression basically
because because our and julia don't
really match up as nicely as python does
we don't convert them automatically back
so what we do get is this our object
back but then this is our copy function
which basically just copies the back
into julia as a whatever is the best
matching type so it does a few different
is it rough here it you can sort of
specify a type to copy those or it'll
try and figure out the best one so for
example our object here the linear model
is really just a named list so it just
converts it back into a dick into a
dictionary and then you know so I get an
article so I'll get a julia dictionary
back if i are copy that model back and
there's various other interfaces java
call you can call LVM write your own LVM
intermediate representation yourself you
can actually do inline assembly that way
if you're really keen so you - Emily in
a dynamic language that's one and cxx is
the new version 0.5 you can actually
write inline c++ which is the engi
compiled using clang because she had the
same back end and then evaluated so you
can literally write C write C++ at your
command line and then it'll be all
nicely valuable you know gets compiled
and run so future directions so we got
some grant by the Moore Foundation
basically improved this sort of data
slide further building this data science
infrastructure so we're looking to build
like a more convenient data manipulation
front ends and let a deep wire link so I
have things basically lots of stuff and
then also improve the data analysis
thing so we've got this compute
framework so I really want to build on
that to make it easy distribute
computations and different back in
support different backends and that sort
of thing
quietly quick plug julie 0.5 is coming
out the next month or so so this will
have something as cool nice features if
anyone's keen and then Julia Khan in the
yeah in a month or in a month enough in
Boston if anyone's a pre-trip or if
you're not I'm sure there'll be plenty
of talks online afterwards you know
watch thank you
that you mix nicely though yeah
yes
if you prefer so if you so if you load
an umpire Ranger Julia where how do you
indexing work so if you wrote if you use
the if you copy it into Julie up then
Julie just sees it as a Julie wrote
array like it act exactly the same as a
Julie array so it uses one based
indexing if you call the Python index
Python get into what's the Python if you
call Python in what's the function it
overloads to get over there to get
indexing if you call the actual Python
indexing function will be zero base yes
yeah there is actually so you can
actually over like change the indexing
yourself but out of spite no one's
created a package to do this instead
they created someone create a two based
indexing package so you can actually if
you really want you can change it to 1 0
based indexing yourself oh yes so this
was all so the standard so this is these
are all inbuilt packages and built from
the import package manager
so basically package this is a package
input package maybe comes with Julia and
then you can install packages from there
and there's nine hundred odd packages on
package up Julie not really but the easy
all you have to do is if you change the
environment variable when you start
Julia you can just point a different
package directory and that's it's it's
slightly in a fish in the sense of it
downloads all the new binary
dependencies again so we're trying to
improve that moment but it's you get the
same functionality as you do with
virtually and literally by just changing
environment variable yeah
I mean this is worth seeing the
definition of dynamical image is
ridiculous but basically we're
dynamically it's dynamically typed but
it acts like I mean the idea is it acts
like you can statically type it if you
really want to you can stick type
assertions everywhere but yeah the type
inference is like fills in for this step
lack of static typing so don't now it's
directly typed and then the type
inference turns essentially turns it
into statically five manage itself I
mean you can but it's not it's not imp
like the style isn't really written for
functional program you can't write
function programming there's like a lazy
front think there's a lazy JL which like
makes it really easy to write lazy like
lazy evaluation and flow rate isn't
things so you can't do it but generally
it's just easier to write the standard
imperative
I mean someone apply throw in this n so
if you can do lazy you know function
program Python but it's really
imperative language yet yes
you don't get a warning yourself but
there is a macro called code one type
which will essentially does that that
code type thing I swayed and then the
ones you have changed principal in red
so yes you can get the same because
they're generic functions it does
actually know what the types are until
you actually call it so you have to has
to do you know but it's probably died by
winter yeah so it's quite we've got
quite a good usage in academia because
basically a lot of people go have their
simulations they're just not you know
simulations or big models they're not
fast enough and so especially coming
from MATLAB it's a big popular
everything it's very easy to sell to
MATLAB users because no one likes paying
for license fees and MATLAB is obviously
terrible not a great language so it's
actually very easy sell hours pretty
easy sell as well because we've got this
you know beat you know praying leo is
always slow so it's easy to coming from
are it's very today sell those as well
pythons a bit tougher because python is
actually self is a fairly good language
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
packages in Python that can get you
around the slow bits and so you know
like number and that sort of thing so
there are I mean we do have number
obviously Z you know can only really do
sort of tight loops maybe we can't go
beyond what number can achieve and those
sort of things but generally there's
enough hack is enough things in Python
and huge ecosystem you can usually find
something that will fill the gap so yes
I'd like to try a Julie a bit and you
know we're coming after you but it's you
know I think I probably got every time
right thanks